two police officers wounded in the
shootout with Ahmed rouhani have been
released from the hospital happy
officers there officer Peter hammer was
to start yesterday was a support and
cheers as you hear from his colleagues
both he and officer on help India are
expected to make a full recovery
Michelle Miller is in elizabeth new
jersey where we're learning more about
rouhani's past Michelle good morning
good morning raha me moved to the United
States from Afghanistan when he was just
a baby and as we well know he lived here
in Elizabeth with his family above this
fried chicken restaurant which was owned
by his father but folks who knew him
growing up say he was shot which makes
the events of this weekend even more
shocking to them wasn't super popular
wasn't captain the football team or prom
king or anything like that high school
classmate Chris kanya says Achmed conv
ha me was quiet and didn't cause trouble
he didn't speak much he you know he was
in the center of attention as a teenager
raha me and a girlfriend had a child
who's now in elementary school according
to custody papers filed on Tuesday the
estranged couple haven't spoken since
January rouhani made trips to
Afghanistan and Pakistan in his early
20s where he married Isaiah BB raha me a
native of Kabul Afghanistan and in 2014
he worked to bring her to the US he
wanted to know what the problem was with
his wife passport and visa to get into
the country New Jersey congressman albio
sierra's says his office denies rami's
wife a visa she was found to be 35 weeks
pregnant and would have needed Pakistani
passports for both herself and her baby
to gain entry it was a routine inquiry
basically you know it was not and there
was no reason for us to suspect anything
raha meas wife eventually entered the US
but left in June sources tell CBS News
she was scheduled to return this week
and is cooperating with authorities but
some family members had concerns ro
hommies father Mohammed says he told the
FBI
I to look into his son during a heated
argument in the family's home in 2014 a
senior law enforcement official tells
CBS News Achmed Khan raha me stabbed his
brother in the leg neighbors heard his
father then call him a terrorist now the
FBI never spoke directly to Achmed they
said that their investigation did not
find any ties to terrorism and his
father actually recanted the story he
told saying he spoke out of anger Jeff
Michelle thanks very much